alright time for audience questions
we've got three good ones first one I
don't know what's going to happen I
predict many many dislikes no matter
what my answer is to this question Chris
wrote in and other people have as well
and Chris said David where are you on
the Sam cedar versus Jimmy Dore debate
which side are you on for people who
don't know Sam cedar is the host of the
majority report podcast and for he's
formerly of Air America and MSNBC
contributor multiple voices he does on
Bob's Burgers etcetera friend of mine
Jimmy Dore is the host of I think it's
the Jimmy Dore shut every door show
Jimmy door show which is under the young
turks umbrella i believe and they've
been kind of going at it and they've
been going at it for even since before
the election and i think before the
election they debated a Bernie or bust
or not and I think if I recall correctly
Jimmy Dore was a Bernie ER Buster and
Sam cedar was not who said no that
doesn't really make any sense that's
that that's not a good idea and they
debated there and then recently they
also had another one of these flare-ups
I guess you would call them and anyway
that the the left left-wing media
particularly online left-wing media has
sort of split up into these different
factions and I think it's totally
destructive and I'm also going to
participate in that now by taking aside
so blame me for what I'm criticizing no
doubt no listen I'm if I had to pick a
side I'm on the Sam cedar side I don't
think that would be a surprise to
anybody on this i I've been following
both I watch about equal amounts of both
jimmy dore and sam cedar and i think
that sam is doing a completely different
type of thing than Jimmy is I don't I
just flat-out don't agree with Jimmy
with a lot of his I guess they would be
called analyses when it comes to Trump
Russia I think that he's been going out
of his way sort of to almost Mock the
idea that there is anything there with
the Russia story when listen we've got
multiple indictments Michael Flynn is on
the chopping block all this crazy stuff
is going on you know and I also do think
that Sam is not doing politics in a way
that is destructive to the movement of
the
I question whether Jimmy's brand of
politics and the way he does it is
actually counterproductive to the left
because I think he and I would probably
agree that the Democratic Party does
need to move to the left like he and I
wouldn't disagree on that but I think
that the approach he takes is one that
is actually going to further the divide
actually rather than actually try to fix
the problem that the left is dealing
with right now so when you talk about
the split when it comes to progressive
talk shows do you mean the Hillary and
Bernie wings do you mean the sjw types
versus the more free speech absolutist
do you mean those who believe in and
agree with the Russia story versus those
who deny it
I don't think it's one thing and I think
it's bigger than the Democratic Party
because there are elements of the left
that are outside the Democratic Party
right so yes they're within the
Democratic Party there's debate as to
whether it's Democrats Inc or do we need
a more progressive Democratic Party etc
etc abundantly clear that public opinion
on issues tells us that the Democratic
Party does need to move to the left but
there are also people on the Left that
are outside the Democratic Party who
would never consider even voting for a
Democrat because they see the party in
and of itself as part of the problem
that's not an illegitimate position to
take you can take that position and
defend it and I think that's interesting
I've never been a Democrat right I
completely respect that point of view
but I don't think it's just it's very
easy to characterize it as the
authoritarian left versus the non
authoritarian left or the sjw's versus
the non sjws or the regressive left
versus the non regressive or the
Democratic Left versus the not in the
Democratic it's all of these things and
more and these issues overlap and Sam
had a very interesting analogy to what
he sees as the problem the difference
between him and Jimmy Dore and Sam said
you know Jimmy Dore and I could both be
out there advocating that hey you need
water water is necessary for life and
I'm advocating for more water but the
difference is Jimmy is offering arsenic
tainted water to people right hey listen
we're on the same side we're think
people need the water but if one of us
is offering or selling arsenic tainted
water then that does not exactly mean
that we are on the same page
even though we might have this general
umbrella opinion that is the same and I
think that's a pretty good analogy so
hey listen if this is if I'm now in a
beef with Jimmy or it makes absolutely
no difference to me that's the thing I'm
just here doing my show you know what
I'm not worried that you're rolling
around in the mud now a lot of them know
I mean I am I'm absolutely rolling
around in the mud but that that's been a
problem we've been dealing with on the
show for a while right no matter what
stories we do we're rolling around in
the mud because we're doing the wrong
stories according to someone but the
beautiful thing is Sam can do his show
and Jimmy can do his show and I can do
my show and if we don't want none of us
have to watch each other's shows or ever
talk about them unless we choose to very
good all right thanks Chris